قال مراسل الجزيره ان قوات الاحتلال حاصرت
مخيم نور شمس شرقه الكرم وان جيش الاحتلال
ارسل عشرات الاليات مدعومه بجرافات قبل
اعلان حظر التجوال في المخيم وكانت قوات
الاحتلال قد اقتحمت في وقت سابق المدينه
من محورها الغربي قبل الانسحاب منها
والتوجه نحو
المخيم اخر التطورات في الضفه نستعرضها مع
مراسل الجزير ليث جعار الموجود في طولكرم
ليث نعم قبل لحظات قليله وصلت تعزيزات
عسكريه اسرائيليه جديده من بوابه 104 غرب
المدينه باتجاه شارع السكه وصولا الى مخيم
نور شمس حيث في هذه اللحظات قوات الاحتلال
تحاصر مخيم نور شمس من كافه المحاور وبدات
باعمال التدمير والتخريب داخل هذا المخيم
ما يزيد عن 50 اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه
اقتحمت في هذه الليله مخيم نور شمس برفقه
على الاقل ثلاثه جرافات وصلت الى المخيم
وبدات باعمال البح الحفر والتجريف للبن
التحتيه في المخيم قوات الاحتلال تحاصر في
هذه اللحظات انحاء عده من المخيم جبل
الصالحين جبل النصر وايضا وسط المخيم
وساحه المخيم ومنطقه حي المشيه وا قوات
الاحتلال تحاول في هذه اللحظات او تقوم ب
الدفع بالتعزيز العسكريه الاسرائيليه الى
مخيم نور شمس في هذه الليله تم رصد ما
يزيد عن 50 اليه عسكريه بالفعل وصلت من
المنطقه الغربيه الشماليه باتجاه مخيم نور
شمس للبدء بالفعل باعمال المداهمه
والتدمير جرافات الدي 9 التي تعمل في هذه
اللحظات على حفر الطرق تقوم ايضا بتدمير
وا الارتطام بجدران المنازل داخل هذا
المخيم وا محاوله لتدمير ايضا جدران
المنازل الخارجيه في المخيم نتحدث عن
الاقتحام الثاني خلال عره ايام فقط لمدينه
طول كرم ومخيم نور شمس وطول الكرم حيث في
الاقتحام السابق كان هناك اقتحام استمر 46
ساعه لمخيم طول كرم وفي هذه الاثناء بدا
بالفعل الاقتحام الموسع لمخيم نور شمس حيث
اعلن الاحتلال قبل قليل حظر التجوال داخل
هذا المخيم اي منع دخول مركبات الاسعاف
وايضا تحرك المواطنين وخروجهم او دخولهم
الى المخيم شرا ليث جعار منت الكرم شكرا
جزيلا لك